où
ok c'est à dire
à quatre bras
c'est rien ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est sérieux mais [ __ ] j'suis kabyè
fois tu m'as [ __ ]
dit on est obligé d'aller dans un trou
paumé comme ça et on dira décor de film
ben voila je le sentais ya pas de réseau
open web 0 bord j'étais une petite
angoisse mais ça va mieux ça dit qu'elle
j'ai tout pour l'angoissent passa
casting pour un film à hollywood mec
jaloux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a tout seul j'ai vu qu'il avait des
grosses cordes
mes grands yeux
ce que quelqu'un un mouchoir ta gueule à
la montre et moi votre côté pienaar
et wahaha
alors quelle est la cible mammifères ou
d'êtres humains ont la pire soirée de
tout même
bon
maintenant
koumé wahaha bravo à toute l'équipe
c'était super mais pas de monstre
c'était une mise en scène fait j'ai fait
un casting est pas longtemps j'ai peur
mais c'était
ah [ __ ] tu pars
tous quel bar tu parles